بعيدا عن احياء العاصمه التونسيه الراقيه
تبدو احوال المواطنين هنا اشد قسوه يطال
ارتفاع الاسعار كل شيء تقريبا فضلا عن نقص
في المواد الغذائيه والادويه كما رفعت
السلطات واسعار الوقود الثلاثه مرات خلال
العام الحالي يقول الخبراء ان الاقتصاد
التونسي على الحافه لكنه بعيدا عن السقوط
اذ قفز معدل التضخم الى مستوى قياسي قارب
العشره في المئه خلال نوفمبر الماضي وهو
ما لم تعد تونس منذ تسعينيات القرن الماضي
عشان نتكلم على تقريبا
كل الفئات اليوم متاثره همم على الجميع
تعاني تونس ركودا في الاقتصاد اذا قبل
تفشي كورونا ثم تفاقم خلال الجائحه وبعدها
وصولا الى تاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا
المباشر على اسعار الحبوب والطاقه في تونس
كما في معظم الدول الاخرى
الحكومه بالوضع الاقتصاديه المتدهور وتقر
ايضا ان العام المقبل لن يكون اقل صعوبه
وضمن مساعي انعاش الاقتصاد المنهج توصلت
السلطات الى اتفاق على مستوى الخبراء مع
صندوق النقد الدولي تحصل بموجبه تونس على
حوالي مليار و900 مليون دولار على مدى
اربع سنوات
ذاك الاتفاق يواجه عقبات عده ليس اقلها
معارضه الاتحاد التونسي العام للشغل
المؤسسه النقابيه الاقوى في البلاد الذي
يرفض رفع الدعم الحكومي عن السلع الاساسيه
وزياده الضرائب
الوصول الاتفاق النهائي مع صندوق النقد
الدولي المقرر خلال الشهر الجاري اذ يشترط
ان تنفذ الحكومه التونسيه برنامج اصلاحات
اقتصاديه وبنيويه تشمل خفض الدعم وتجميد
الاجور